من الأشياء التي
كان الرئيس بايدن يحاول القيام بها في الرحلة على ما أعتقد
هو إيجاد طريقة
لفهم أفضل لما يجب القيام به
حيال إيران وأعتقد أنه كان يحاول إقناع الإسرائيليين والسعوديين على
وجه الخصوص بأنه  في الواقع ، من المنطقي
بالنسبة لإيران أن تذهب والولايات المتحدة
للعودة إلى الاتفاق النووي
الإيراني تضع قيودًا على العراق بشأن برنامج إيران النووي ،
هل تعتقد أن الرئيس بايدن على حق في
حالة ما إذا كنا نحاول جميعًا
إعادة هذه الصفقة معًا.
فاعل رئيسي رئيسي في هذا الجزء
من العالم ، وبالنسبة لي في العراق ، لدينا
حدود طويلة مع إيران ، لدينا جميع
أنواع التفاعلات ،
ومصالح الضمان الاجتماعي الثقافي ، سمها ما شئت ،
لذلك من الواضح أن هذه قضية
عاقبة لنا وهي نتيجة
على نطاق أوسع.  المنطقة والعالم في الواقع
لا توجد حلول عسكرية لهذه ،
نحن بحاجة إلى إغلاق دبلوماسي لهذا
المأزق ،
نحتاج إلى ترتيب أمني في
الشرق الأوسط
حيث يمكننا أن نجتمع معًا لمكافحة
الإرهاب بينما  لا تزال قضية ich مشكلة رئيسية ،
انظر إلى أين تنظر سوريا إلى شمال
سوريا ، انظر إلى المسلحين الموجودين
ويتخذون قاعدة في سوريا والذين لا يزالون يشكلون
تهديدًا حقيقيًا للاستقرار ليس فقط
في الشرق الأوسط ولكن أيضًا للعالم الأبيض
قارن ذلك بأفغانستان في
عام 2001 حيث كان عدد قليل من
الرجال في الكهوف النائية في أفغانستان
وكان بإمكانهم تنفيذ هذا
الهجوم الرهيب في 11 سبتمبر ، والآن
نتحدث عن الآلاف
والآلاف من المسلحين المدربين جيدًا
في قلب الشرق الأوسط الحضري
.  الخطر نحن بحاجة إلى
تجميع الحي
كجزء من بنية مشتركة
للرد على
هذه
العناصر ولكن أيضًا في الحقيقة نتعامل مع
التحديات الأساسية التي يواجهها الشرق الأوسط
تحديات
اقتصادية للوظائف
التي نواجهها مع
المناخ الرهيب
أه
التغيرات التي هي
تؤثر على الحي بأكمله
ولكن دعني أترجم ما أعتقد
أنك تقوله وهو نعم
يجب أن يكون لديك اتفاق نووي نعم ب  لكن
الأمر أكثر من ذلك الذي تتحدث عنه ،
فأنا أفكر في تكامل الجزء الخاص بنا
من العالم ونوع من
المصالحة بين إيران
والعرب بشكل مطلق ، وبالمناسبة ،
يلعب العراق دورًا مهمًا للغاية
في محاولة التوسط بين
السعوديون والإيرانيون كان هناك عدد من
المحادثات التي جرت في
بغداد بين إيران
وجيران عرب آخرين وهناك بعض
الأجواء المهمة التي
تحسنت في نهاية اليوم نحتاج
إلى الجلوس
على نفس الطاولة والتحدث  حول
المشاكل التي تنتج عن
ناخبينا في نهاية اليوم ،
نعم ، أمريكا مهمة ، نعم ، العالم مهم
ولكن أيضًا أولوياتنا الخاصة في الجزء الخاص بنا
من العالم مهمة ولكن هذا ليس
المكان الذي تكون فيه الأمور السيد الرئيس الآن
ما يحدث هو
تقيم المملكة العربية السعودية تحالفًا ضمنيًا
مع إسرائيل ، وقد أقامت الإمارات العربية المتحدة
تحالفًا مفتوحًا بشكل فعال وهذا
يشبه إلى حد كبير استراتيجية الاحتواء القديمة لكاميرا
متحاربة  ملحوظة: أعتقد أن هذا
مرة أخرى إذا عدت إلى التاريخ ،
فهذه وصفة لتكرار
المآسي الرهيبة في الماضي ،
لا يمكن لهذا الجزء من العالم أن يستمر على هذا
النحو ، فنحن محظوظون بامتلاكنا للنفط
ولكن لدينا أيضًا
تحديات اقتصادية خطيرة للغاية  والتحديات الاجتماعية ،
نحتاج إلى بنية تحتية
يمكنها ربط اقتصاداتنا معًا ،
نحتاج إلى إجراءات مشتركة ضد تغير
المناخ ، لا يمكن للعراق القيام بذلك بمفرده.لا تستطيع المملكة
العربية السعودية القيام بذلك بمفردها ، لا تستطيع إيران القيام
بذلك بمفردها.
أن
يتم إعادتنا إلى الحظيرة وأن
نحتاج إلى إيجاد الطريقة التي
نخرج بها سوريا من الفوضى التي تعيشها
اليوم والتي ظلت موجودة لفترة طويلة بينما
نركز
على عناوين
التنافس بين الدولتين بين السعوديين الإيرانيين
هذا وذاك.  في نهاية اليوم ،
هناك تحديات كبيرة حقًا
تواجه كل دولة في هذا
الجزء من العالم لا نريد
العودة إلى أيام الماضي حيث
أصبحنا جزءًا من الوصول مرة أخرى  آخر ، لقد
فعلنا ذلك ودفعنا ثمناً باهظًا مقابل ذلك ،
فلدينا العديد من الأولويات لفعل
ذلك مرة أخرى